[Musique]
aurez vous êtes couillon les césar
si vous en êtes là alors qu'on vient à
peine de démarrer que si vous avez donné
un meilleur des cas sinon je vous
préviens je ne veux pas un mot plus haut
que l'autre sur georges et amal je viens
de passer deux jours avec que ce sont
deux crèmes que le maître de cérémonie
en fait l'invité d'honneur chez lui
c'est une coutume des césars dans ce
fonds est-il un dernière l'a eue michael
douglas sur son clic clac moi je suis
tombé la bonne année pour ouvrir la 42e
cérémonie des césars j'appelle le
président de l'académie des arts et
techniques du cinéma monsieur alain
terzian
vous nous éclabousser de joie de vivre
je suis super super touché super
heureuse merci aux votants merci à
l'académie des césar désolé je peux me
remettre
[Applaudissements]
je vous prie d'excuser mémé cafouillage
les mots tendance à télescopique dans
les moments de joie
celui ci
oui messieurs dames j'avais le trac
j'avais le trac parce que j'ai revu le
petit garçon le minot que j'étais à
grand-quevilly assis dans son fauteuil
en osier en train de regarder cette
télévision grundig noir et blanc et
admirer toutes ces stars assise au
palais des congrès sur les fauteuils
orange jean gabin avec ses grosses
lunettes
jerry lewis remettant un césar d'honneur
avec kirk douglas à louis de funès j'ai
revu tous ces gens et pour un gamin
comme moi qui rêvais de faire du cinéma
forcément c'était magique
ce gamin qui se disait le césar un jour
je le remettrais en fait il ya deux ans
exactement quand j'avais été nommé pour
un autre film ici bruxelles orange avait
retrouvé un article datant de 1999 2 et
enfin faut c'est le petit magazine des
tempes
là où j'ai passé mon enfance et on me
disait qu'est ce que vous rêvez de faire
maintenant que vous êtes rentré au
consommateur de paris je disais mon rêve
ce serait qu'un jour je puisse faire des
concerts où irait toutes les cultures du
monde représentée et de faire des
musiques de films et ben voilà vous êtes
en train d'offrir un magnifique cadeau
merci beaucoup
j'arrive comme ça comment ça comme ça
mais je ne sais pas il n'y a pas un peu
de musique pour m'accompagner terrible
jean bouilhou transcrit famille
[Applaudissements]
nous citoyens du monde nous devons nous
battre très très dur pour que la haine
ne gagne pas et pour que les jo de 2024
ce soit à paris et pas de sanctionner
[Applaudissements]
et montrer qu'ils sont pour remettre le
césar du meilleur film étranger
j'appelle florian philippot non c'était
juste pour vous réveiller un peu à des
dictateurs comme ça moi ce n'est pas un
hommage
c'est une ovation que nous allons offrir
à jean paul belmondo
je veux remercier de tous de poser
applaudissements un savourer droite
hockey
temps quand je vois le trac que j'ai
pour remettre un prix
j'ose pas pensé si c'était moi qu'il
recevait je pense parfois aux rapports
entre l'interprète que je suis et les
rôles que j'ai joués
alors je crois que pour elle est bien le
rôle l'emportent sur l'interprète voilà
parce qu'au fond je jouais pas plus mal
enfin aussi bien peut-être dans d'autres
films mais cette année il semble que
vous l'avez mis en marquer dans l
voilà je suis très touchée par votre
témoignage ce soir parmi tous ces
talents qui brille qui m'impressionne tu
n'es jamais eu avant ce soir l'occasion
de leur exprimer ma gratitude et de leur
dire qu une des choses les plus
précieuses à mes yeux c'est la loyauté
et la mythique hymne ont partagé depuis
que je suis tout petit alors merci
caisse par omar fabrice françois nicolas
pierre et pierre
je suis très honoré de remettre aux
meilleurs d'entre vous ce césar
emblématique
vous le savez ceux qui jouent un peu
moins bien ne leur ont pas
l'occasion de réfléchir à comment
réussir à jouer un peu mieux cette année
et pourquoi pas gagner la timbale
l'année prochaine et oui encore - pardon
gaspard mme ne peut se joindre à nous il
il est en tournage ce soir je pense qu'
il aurait été très heureux d'être ici
évidemment il m'a demandé de le lire ce
texte mais étrangement aussi de ne de le
découvrir en même temps que vous donc
xavier ça commence bien merci
le taux doit tant merci d'offrir à des
acteurs ce qui hors du commun pour
raconter l'ordinaire ce regard que tu
poses sûreté comédien n'a pas
d'équivalent avides de la moindre nuance
transformant le moindre friselis en un
bouleversement supporter à chaque fois
des acteurs dans la fraîcheur et l'éclat
de l'inédit bon bien une chose qui est
très cher et verra si je bats le père et
je vais lui perd tu as fait a ajouté un
niveau supérieur à ce film marche
beaucoup mieux belle gitane
voudrais vous remercier vous le public
des césars pour votre bienveillance et
votre humour merci à tous les jeunes et
parmi nouveau départ
[Applaudissements]